walking into this swirl of angry
protests
this is Joseph Muscat Walters Prime
Minister emerging from a crisis meeting
of his own cabinet to be met by public
fury he may look and sound calm for us
this was not just a murder this was a
major case that shook our democracy but
Muscat had actually just been told that
most of his cabinet had lost faith in
him that his position was untenable and
why well look at the anger of this man
his mother was murdered just over two
years ago he and his brothers are
protesting convinced that muskets
government has hindered the
investigation people know nothing that's
why we're here it's completely absurd
Daphney Caruana Galicia was an
investigative journalist who was killed
by car bomb she had just uncovered links
between ministers and secret bank
accounts arrests were made after the
murder but the government refused to
hold an inquiry but now things are
changing fast businessman Juergen fennec
has been arrested in relation to the
killing muskets chief of staff abruptly
resigned this week and has been
questioned by police and now Prime
Minister Muscat is expected to stand
down all deny any involvement in the
murder that the allegations have tainted
Muscat and his government there haven't
been any resignations when she was alive
that was part of the problem and people
in Muscat government resigned sooner
after he might still be alive today
there is real anger in Malta now I
understand Muscat wants to hand over
power at the end of January others want
him gone
now fearful that the nation's reputation
has been tarnished we need to make sure
that those who are responsible are
placed behind bars and atone for their
sins mascot is a beaten man now a prime
minister whose authority has been
corroded by growing public anger and
mistrust but what happens next will be
crucial for Malta and its people
Adam Parsons Sky News